Hello there, I'm Gavin.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow-Mo Guys and that.
I was watching videos on the internet
and I came across a bloke
called Grant Thompson
who made a match rocket.
Here's one I made earlier.
Mine looks rubbish compared to his,
but we'll see if it works.
He didn't have any slow-mo in his video,
so we're gonna set off
a few match rockets,
film it in slow-mo.
Apparently they can go 40 feet.
His can go 40 feet.
I'm thinking about four feet.
Four feet for you?
Yeah, probably about that.
All right, we'll see how it looks.
Sweet, let's go.
How do these bad boys work then, Daniel?
Just getting the right trajectory.
Basically, there's a match
head in the top there,
and you're gonna heat that
up with a flame of some sort.
Then when it reaches a certain temperature
through the foil, it's going to combust,
causing an expansion of gas
within a sealed foil chamber,
which is being plugged up by this nail.
Then that's gonna cause it to
fire off into the distance.
Video not sponsored by Famous Amos.
They are delicious cookies.
No AdWatch, see?
Gonna film this on the old Phantom Flex.
Two and a half-thousand frames.
Maybe we should hit you
in the face with it.
T minus some seconds.
Whoa.
That one went.
That was a good distance.
That was good, though.
Probably about 20 feet,
something like that.
That's like a miniature actual rocket.
Flame blast-off; that's wicked.
That's some enthusiasm.
That's cool.
I love the little--
The fins actually stabilize it.
It's cool as hell.
I love the little trail of smoke.
It's so satisfying. It makes a good sound.
It's like a pop.
It's heading right for the house.
You can see it changing
directions, though.
That's wicked.
Course corrections.
Okay, here's the facial impact.
I'm gonna say 10 points for the nose
and five points for anything else
if it's on your head.
Sounds good.
Three, two, one.
Oh, God.
hit me in the eye.
Good Lord.
Oh my God.
That was great.
Straight for you.
Little fly ball.
It's even spinning-looking, yeah.
You've seen it, you've seen it.
Smack.
Right in your eye.
Right in the visor.
Jesus.
That's great.
That couldn't have gone better.
Five points.
Your face.
You got a sore eye from that.
I thought that video worked tremendously.
Straight in your eye.
Yeah, it was literally directly.
satisfying clunk
when it hit the goggles as well.
I was actually debating goggles.
I was like, "Is it really
gonna go in your eye?"
Yes, absolutely.
Yes it is, yeah.
It's weird 'cause I actually reacted to it
as if it actually hit my eye.
I was like, "Oh, I've got goggles on."
Thanks to Grant Thompson
for the inspirashe for that video.
It was pretty cool.
Inspirashe.
You can actually watch a video
on how to make these little match rockets.
The link is in the description.
Feel free to follow us on the twits.
Buy a shirt if you want.
If Dan sees you wearing a shirt,
that is, a Slow-Mo Guys shirt,
he will buy you a drink.
Why do you always do this?
It's in his contract.
Order a really expensive one.
Order a martini or something.
Cocktail, something like that.
Cocktails, yeah, mojito.
Also, subscribe to the channel
'cause there's a bunch of slow-mo on it.
There's over 100 videos these days.
Sweet.
What are you laughing at?
These days.
Oh yeah.
Good concentration face there.
Was that good?
Yeah.
Hang on, do it again.
Get this.
This is my concentration face; ready?
Yeah.
Nice. Good work.
Too much?
No, no, it's good.